FOR ALL THE LATEST UPDATES FROM
THE GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK.
MEANWHILE, IT IS AN EASTER LIKE
NO OTHER FOR OUR TROOPS
OVERSEAS.
MILITARY CHAPLAINS COMING UP
WITH UNIQUE WAYS TO MARK THIS
HOLY DAY SAFELY.
INCLUDING DRIVE-UP COMMUNION
RIGHT AFTER THE LIVE STREAMED
MASS AT A UF POST IN JAPAN.
JOINING US NOW THE MAN BEHIND
THAT IDEA, LIEUTENANT COLONEL
DON IRKE, CHAPLAIN FOR THE U.S.
ARMY AT THE CAMP IN JAPAN.
THANKS SO MUCH FOR DOING THIS.
YOU SAW WHAT YOU WERE DOING AND
THOUGHT OUR VIEWERS WOULD LOVE
-- HAPPY EASTER TO YOU.
WE THOUGHT OUR VIEWERS WOULD
LOVE TO HEAR WHAT YOU ARE DOING
FOR OUR TROOPS OVERSEAS ON THIS
EASTER SUN DAY.
>> WE’RE DOING SOME REMARKABLE
THINGS, SOME CREATIVE THINGS.
DOING THINGS A LITTLE
DIFFERENTLY THAN WE NORMALLY DO.
BUT THE COMMUNITY’S REALLY
RESPONDED WELL TO IT.
YOU MENTIONED THE DRIVE-UP
COMMUNION, OUR CATHOLIC PRIEST,
HE GAME UP WITH THAT IDEA.
-- CAME UP WITH THAT IDEA.
BECAUSE IT’S SO IMPORTANT TO
RECEIVE COMMUNION AND AT FIRST I
THOUGHT -- I LAUGHED AND THEN I
THOUGHT, WELL, THAT’S JUST CRAZY
ENOUGH TO WORK AND REALLY JUST
HOW INSPIRED AND INDEED THE
COMMUNITY’S RESPONDED WELL.
THE CARS LINE UP EVERY SUNDAY
AFTER MASS.
THEY STAY IN THEIR VEHICLES AND
THEY ARE ALL ABLE TO RECEIVE
COMMUNION.
THEY RECEIVE THE BLESSING FROM
FATHER AZARI AND OUR PROTESTANT
FOLKS ARE DOING THE SAME THING
AS WELL.
IT’S A MATTER OF THINKING
CREATIVELY, THINKING
DIFFERENTLY.
WE DON’T HAVE A GAME PLAN TO
CALL UPON FROM LAST YEAR.
IT’S JUST PEOPLE COMING UP WITH
GOOD IDEAS AND IMPLEMENTING
THOSE IDEAS AND TAKING ADVANTAGE
OF WHAT THERE IS STILL AVAILABLE
FOR US TO DO EVEN AS WE ARE
PRACTICING SOCIAL DISTANCING.
SANDRA:  CHAPLAIN, WHAT IS THE
TROOP MORALE THROUGHOUT ALL OF
THIS?
>> OUR TROOP MORALE IS REALLY
HIGH.
OUR FOLKS ARE 100% BEHIND
LEADERSHIP AND PEOPLE UNDERSTAND
EXACTLY WHAT THEY NEED TO DO TO
KEEP THEMSELVES SAFE AND MORE
IMPORTANTLY ALSO TO KEEP ONE
ANOTHER SAFE.
THIS IS A COMMUNITY EFFORT.
IT’S VERY COLLABORATIVE AND
PEOPLE HAVE KEPT THEIR SPIRITS
HIGH.
SOMETIMES IT’S REALLY DIFFICULT
ESPECIALLY SEE THE NEWS FROM
BACK IN THE STATES.
I DON’T THINK THERE IS ANY
FAMILY HERE THAT IS NOT IMPACTED
BY WHAT’S HAPPENING IN AMERICA.
BUT YET WE KEEP OUR HOPES HIGH.
WE’RE VERY RESILIENT.
AND WE STAY STRONG.
SANDRA:  THAT IS A VERY POSITIVE
MESSAGE AND SOMETHING WONDERFUL
TO HEAR ON THIS EASTER MORNING,
CHAPLAIN.
AND WE’VE BEEN SHOWING PICTURES
THERE OF CAMP ZUMA AND THE
SERVICES THAT HAVE BEEN GOING
ON, THE DRIVE-UP SERVICES AND
EVEN LITTLE EASTER BAGS WERE
THERE TO HAND OUT.
SO YOU PULL UP IN YOUR CAR, JUST
LIKE THE DRIVE-IN MOVIE, AND YOU
TUNE INTO THE STATION THERE AND
YOU HEAR THE SERVICE AND YOU GO
AWAY WITH YOUR EASTER BAG.
LEAVE US OFF WITH THE RESPONSE
THAT YOU’VE BEEN GETTING TO ALL
OF THIS.
>> IT’S BEEN FANTASTIC.
PEOPLE REALLY RESPONDED WELL.
THEY LOVED IT.
THEY LOVE THE IDEA.
FOR THOSE OF US WHO REMEMBER
DRIVE-INS, YES, IT HAS THE
APPEAL OF PEOPLE DRIVING UP,
TAKETHEY GOT THEIR EASTER BAG TH
VOLUNTEERS PUT TOGETHER AND WE
MADE SURE IT WAS DONE WITH GREAT
CARE TO MAKE SURE WE DIDN’T
SPREAD THE VIRUS.
IT WAS DONE VERY CAREFULLY AND
THEY TUNED IN TO FM   88.9 AND
WERE ABLE TO HEAR US THROUGH THE
TRANSMITTER AND STAYED TOGETHER
WITH ONE ANOTHER INSIDE THEIR
CARS BUT STILL TOGETHER AS A
COMMUNITY AS WELL.
IT’S SO IMPORTANT TO KEEP --
EVEN AS WE’RE PRACTICING SOCIAL
DISTANCING, THAT WE STILL HAVE
THAT SENSE OF COMMUNITY IS STILL
THERE AND I THINK PEOPLE REALLY
HAVE THE RESPONSES, THEY’VE
REALLY FELT LIKE THEY HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO WORSHIP TOGETHER
AS A GROUP EVEN AS WE WERE
SEPARATE IN OUR CARS AND DOING
IT OVER THE RADIO, THERE’S THAT
SENSE OF BELONGING AND
TOGETHERNESS THAT WE SO LONG
FOR, IT’S SO IMPORTANT FOR US,
IT’S A PART OF OUR FAITH AND
PRACTICE.
SANDRA:  CHAPLAIN IRKE, YOU’RE
ALSO LIEUTENANT: LIEUTENANT COLO
IRKE.
THANK YOU FOR WHAT YOU’RE DOING
TO KEEP SPIRITS HIGH DURING